محطه على الشفير الكارثه تحذير تطلقه
موسكو وتدعو الى اداره الطرف المسؤول عن
القصف تحميل روسيا لاوكرانيا مسؤوليه
القصف الاخر
الذي طالب نيته بحمايه المفاعلات من تخريب
روسي وان كان خبراء الوكاله الدوليه لا
يزالون في طور اجراء تقيين للاضرار في
المحطه تظهر مخاوف غربيه اخرى على بولندا
واسطه تاهو بالنشر صواريخ لحمايتها لكن
ذلك
كشف ايضا عن مشكلات يعاني منها
النيترولاسيما في بنيته تحتيه على الجبهه
الشرقيه
اشرف اذا الخبراء الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه تقييما للوضع في محطه زبروجيا في
اوكرانيا وذلك بعد ساعات من تعرضها لقصف
تبادل الروس والاوكرانيون الاتهامات
بشانهم وقد اتهم الجانب الاوكراني روسيا
بقصف المحطه وقالت وكاله الوكاله دوليه
للطاقه ذريه او الوكاله عفوا يعني الوكاله
نوويه الاوكرانيه قالت ان اثنتين 10 ضربه
على الاقل سجلت في موقع المحطه ملتهمه
روسيا بتعريض العالم باسره للخطر تعبيرها
وده الرئيس الاوكراني سكيت دولا احد في
شمال الاطلسي الى ضمان حمايه المفاعلات
النوويه الاوكرانيه من اي تخريب روسي وقال
ان من مصلحه جميع الدول الا تقع اي احداث
خطيره في المنشاه واضاف في كلمه عبر
الفيديو خلال الجلسه العامه للجمعيه
البرلمانيه
وفي مشكله المتحدثه باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخلوظه دعت الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه الى اتخاذ موقف مسؤول
ومطالبه السلطات الاوكرانيه بوقف قصف محطه
زبرجه للطاقه النوويه
وقالت زخرفه في بيان نشر على موقع الوزاره
انه يجب الابتعاد عن الادانات والمطالب
المجرده بوقفي قصف محطه زبروجيا دون
الاشاره بوضوح ودون لبس الى دون لبس الى
اولئك الذين نفذوا الجماعه
وينضم الينا من فينا روبرتسكريه المدير
السابق في الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الدريه
اهلا بك سيد روبرتسكري
ما الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في هذه المساله
تحديدا
الوكاله الدوليه
متاكدا انهم لديهم الكفاء النظري وتفحصي
انابيب المياه وانا اشك اذا ما كان لديهم
الكفاءه لاي
لانه من اين اتت الاصابه او اطلاق النار
لانه هنالك مزاعم من الطرفين ويتم استخدام
فيها نفس الاسلحه تقريبا الاسلحه ربما
السوفيتي بالتالي سيكون من الصعب جدا
تحديد جهه التي اطلقت هذا الهجوم
سيد روبرت لان كان الطرفين يعني كلاهما
يتبادل او يتهم الطرف الاخر بانه المسؤول
عن ضرب المحطه هل هناك اليات محدده طريقه
عمل اسلوب عملي يسمح لخبراء الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه باثبات الطرف او
تحديد الطرف المسؤول عن قصر المحطه
كلا على الاطلاق لا اعتقد ان الوكاله
لديها التدريب او الخبره في ما يتعلق
بالنظر الى الانظمه انظمه الاسلحه ومن قام
باطلاق الاسلحه ومن ترك اثرا مثلا حفره في
الارض هذه ليست المهارات او التدريب التي
يحظى بها خبراء الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه شكرا جزيلا لك روبرت كيليا المدير
السابق في الوكاله الدوليه